I'm Shanon McWeeny I'm the division head
for bioinformatics and computational
biology normally these sessions are in
seed and by Bill her she's our chair
he's away I think he's in DC or some
other parts of the planets and today is
a PhD symposium and for those of you who
have not been to one of these before
this is something for our doctoral
students that allows them as they're
preparing so this is not a proposal
defense so they're starting to think
about the ideas in which they'll
formulate eventually their proposal and
the work that they want to do for their
dissertation but this is really for them
to explore the field and start to think
about where some of the low-hanging
fruit are so these actually can be
really rich for other people attending
in terms of ideas your input and
questions are actually critical in a
symposium so please feel free to ask
questions I'm assuming you want to pull
them to the end yeah so if we can hold
the questions to the end we do record
this too what we ask is that you raise
your hand over with a mic otherwise what
will happen on the video is no one will
hear the question and then then I'll
just be talking so we'll do that I'm
gonna briefly from his prepared bio just
introduce Ben to you currently he's one
of our pre doctoral fellows he's on the
NIE HS fellowship he received his BA in
Psychology the concentration was in
neuro psych in 2011 his MS is from here
and I was able to convince him to
continue on to do a PhD he worked before
as a software developer creating
immersive data visualizations website
games and other forms of interactive
media for the web before he came back to
do his masters and then eventually his
PhD here and his current research
projects involve modeling NGS error
rates and sequencing experiments which
had clinical applications that was part
of his master's thesis as well as
theoretical applications of quantum
algorithms for biology medicine
environmental health and that's the
focus of the symposium through that
second part his broad research interest
include cancer genomics medical imaging
machine learning algorithms data
visualization complexity quantum
computing quantum algorithms which I
believe is what we call everything in
parentheses he likes it all and of
course today is his doctoral symposium
so this algorithm was a way of making
recommendation systems more efficient
and exponentially more efficient in fact
and interestingly in July of this year
there was a paper published by a student
at University of Texas Austin called
Ellen tang and he was working with his
advisor Scott Aaronson and Scott Henson
had said for his senior thesis he should
try and kind of close out the theory
around whether quantum computation in
this specific instance for
recommendation problem actually should
provide a an exponential speed-up over
the classical algorithm and
interestingly he kind of went around
this problem for a quite a few months
and then finally kind of said to Anson
you know I think that this actually
isn't true I think potentially there's a
classical algorithm that could be as
efficient as a quantum algorithm and in
July of this year he published that
algorithm and it actually kind of was
pretty pretty interesting because it
showed that you could think in terms of
quantum information theory and possibly
get some algorithms that are different
and more efficiently the classical ones
be developed today so to kind of get
started my roadmap I'll provide some
historical context I'll talk about
quantum systems and some quantum
algorithms and kind of really discuss
some basics and then potential
applications for biology medicine some
existing barriers and gaps that as I've
seen them and then I'll open it up to
discussion so its first some historical
context and this is largely a story of
complexity and scalability so in 1936
Alonzo Church and Alan Turing proposed
what's known as the church-turing thesis
and this was essentially the combination
of two theories they developed that were
shown to be equivalent and you can sum
it up essentially that any algorithmic
process can be simulated using a Turing
machine which is more or less equivalent
to a digital computer and so this this
theory has kind of you know gone some
revisions undergone some revisions but
more or less it's held up but as we've
developed real computer
and we've actually started to solve
problems with them it's become clear
that there are actually other
constraints and so those constraints can
really put be put down to two major
components which is time complexity and
space complexity and together we'll
generally call them computational
complexity for this talk I'll really
focus on the time complexity component
though so what is it
well canonical algorithms usually have
an established time in space complexity
and time complexity and can be described
using a mathematical formalism and what
it what it seeks to do is you know
assess the number of elementary
computations relative to the size of the
input of a function and so one of the
most interesting ones is known as Big O
notation and this is the worst case
formalism so this is the idea that if
you have an input of a given size what's
the worst case how large will be
solution space that you have to explore
B with the size of that input and that
this this way of thinking about
algorithms has actually supported a
quite a rich structure in completely
computational complexity theory and it
really you know it really kind of speaks
to some of the practical constraints
it's it has its limitations and so what
does this actually look like is that if
we imagine a problem with a linear they
go we see that the input which is not
shown here the output is essentially the
same we have you know a linear growth
and then we also have polynomial growth
where we have an exponent say 2 or 3 and
these are generally considered easier
tractable problems and then we also have
exponential growth which I've dimmed
maybe a bit prematurely and this this is
where we have a doubling of the solution
space every time we increase the input
by one bit and so these problems are
generally considered intractable by
digital computers and there's some ways
we can kind of get traction and I'll go
over that but more or less those are
considered to be very hard problems you
may be wondering why polynomial is
considered easy after
example like ten to the twelve is one
trillion so if you had a ten book bit
input you would have a trillion you know
kind of possible solutions to explore
and the reality is you know we only
really see low polynomial growths
most of the time and you can call it a
perk of living in a three-dimensional
world so the second portion of this is
the scalability of classical computers
so in the 60s gordon moore quite
famously gave the idea of moore's law
which is that the number of excuse me
the number of gates on a single
processor doubles every two years to 18
months and this has largely been an
imperfect but pretty good bulwark
against the growth of these poems in a
lot of spaces so we've been able to do a
lot of really interesting computational
modeling because of the scaling of these
chips and how many how many bits and
logical gates we can fit onto these
processors but the reality is we're
actually fundamentally reaching a limit
and this is an atomic limit they're
these gates are getting so small they're
subject to atomic interference and
things of that nature so in 2005 Gordon
Moore stated we have another 10 to 20
years before we reach this fundamental
limit and it's now 2018 and particularly
in the realm of scientific computing at
among the computational is here I'm sure
we can agree that the amount of data
were generating sometimes we really
can't get traction on certain problems
and get certain answers and so the
question is what do we do at this
juncture and they're effectively two
approaches ones as old as computation
itself and the other is actually
fundamentally new and I'm gonna start
with the old so the old is essentially
we can use different techniques to make
problems more tractable we can constrain
the input space we can constrain the
output space and we can also use a
technique called memoization where we're
essentially storing expensive
computations that we can reuse for later
if they come up again we can also apply
domain knowledge such as you know will
the worst place ever really occur it's
actually pretty common that it doesn't
so that's so that's really great and
then there's also a question of is there
or not
space time trade-off and this is this is
not really a solidly defined thing as
far as I know but Nina is a ssin for
example is is something that does kind
of trade space and time complexity a
little bit and then we can also do
parallelization that's been really
useful for the last you know 10 or 15
years and the the reality though is that
parallelization is every time you double
the number of parallel instances for a
computation you only get half the
benefit of the previous of the previous
speed-up you got so it has diminishing
returns and so the second thing is we
could think about you know how quantum
computation could work because you know
these are basically the tiniest
particles that you know we really know
exist in the physical universe and and
so in proceeding one of the people who
really proposed this and was 1981 in
1981 Richard Feynman and he uh you know
he well he didn't really propose quantum
computation he really got the idea that
quantum computation may be a more
efficient model than our classical
digital computation and so what he
really suggested was that because the
quantum computer may perform
calculations more efficient particularly
in modeling quantum systems it may
actually also be useful for a classical
for classical problems and then further
in 1985 we had David Dortch who proposed
actually a quantum model for computation
and these together really kind of
started to push the field towards like
you know really a theoretical grounding
and serious development and so well as I
said you know find and skip that so so
as so to give you an example of why
classical bits can simulate a quantum
system back you know Assoc has a growth
in this exponential solution space if we
were to model naively a quantum system
with 50 cubits or quantum bits of
information
it would take 1.125 quadrillion
classical bits exactly and so you can
imagine modeling a system that's very
small with a classical computer is
actually very hard and so what does this
provide if we kind of flip the approach
that you know a quantum computer or a
quantum system basically has this
exponential blow-up and we say okay well
we have this exponential space what if
we can use that to kind of do classical
computations we we can kind of kind of
come up with some interesting ideas
about how to solve problems and so in
the intervening decade since Fineman
Deutsch we've seen collaborations
between physicists mathematicians
engineers computer scientists and even
chemists and these Labor's have led to
the development of multiple hardware
architectures and constant for quantum
computation and the formalization of
many algorithms and the description of
theoretical applications along with a
handful of real-world examples of those
applications from this body of work
particularly computer science it's
become clear that quantum computation
may hold the potential to make certain
exponentially bounded problems more
tractable and so what we're talking
about is the marune line right there
certain classes or certain examples of
np-hard problems may be more attractable
with a quantum computational model and
so before going any further the question
is well so what is it what is quantum
computation and so I'm going to try and
provide like a five to ten minute
intuition around this and hopefully
it'll be it'll resonate so computers are
fundamentally state machines and
crossbolt computers as I'm sure you all
know use bits of information and
manipulate these and their higher-order
representations using algorithms and
these bits are either a 1 or a 0 and
quantum computing is actually
fundamentally different because it
operates on qubits instead of classical
bits and these can be particles such as
an electron or a photon they can be a
superconn
the circuit trapped I own a quantum dot
really any system that exhibits quantum
mechanical properties and so there are
four properties that I'm going to
outline that are relevant to quantum
systems and in some cases unique and
they are superposition entanglement
interference and tunneling and so I'll
start with superposition so a quantum
system can be comprised of this qubit
here and we can actually put it into a
superposition where it is neither a 1 or
a 0 but essentially a state in between
or a probabilistic state and all quantum
systems have an Associated wave function
and that's really important and I'll get
to what that means later and we can
actually represent this with thematic
mathematical formulas and the
Schrodinger equation but I won't go into
that and so the probability amplitudes
that we see in this superposition are
really interesting and when we measure a
quantum theta actually collapses to one
state so either a 1 or a 0 and this is
based off of the probability amplitude
it was encoding the second most perhaps
astounding property in my mind is this
idea of quantum entanglement and it's
often described as correlations between
parts of the quantum system Einstein
talked about it as spooky action at a
distance and it's distinct from any
phenomena we observed in classical
physics and so when we create a fully
entangled system of qubits and in
equipment when we create a fully
entangled system of qubits in
superposition for a quantum system we
can represent an exponential number of
states so for one bit we have you know
two possible states but if we entangle
to two bits
we actually have four possible states
and then every to tangle three qubits we
have 8 possible States and so you can
see you're essentially having the state
space as you entangle grow exponentially
and so this potentially opens this
really large state space that you can
model
and so being able to manipulate these
entangle states in what's known as
hilbert space is essentially a major
reason why quantum computing is believed
to be more powerful within classical
computing so another concept is quantum
interference and this is the idea that a
quantum system as we discussed can
occupy a probabilistic Hilbert space or
sorry so this is the idea effectively
that we have we we have essentially is
probably probability amplitudes and
their representative it's waves and all
of these quantum systems can be
represented as a wave function and so if
we leverage the properties of
entanglement and these probability
amplitudes we can actually interfere to
amplify and cancel out amplitude so this
is what it would look like and this is
actually somewhat analogous to when you
where sound-canceling headphones they're
essentially phasing the sounds that in
the environment to cancel them out and
so what we can do with this is we can
actually amplify probabilities for
solutions to cancel probabilities for
non solutions if we're really clever
about how we apply these these
techniques and so the final final
property is known as quantum tunneling
and if we it helps to describe this to
imagine an energy landscape so here we
have one and the green dots represent
local minima as we go down a gradient
and the red dot at the bottom is a
global minima and so in optimization we
really want to minimize an energy
function and this is the same ideas in
the machine learning too and so we're
essentially traversing down this
gradient and we we ideally want to avoid
these local minima but as we're stepping
and walking down if our steps you know
not big enough we won't be able to hop
out of the wells as we meet them so
we'll just get stuck and that's maybe a
good solution but it's not the optimum
right here
you know conversely if our step is too
big we're just going to hop around and
we're not really going to hit a hit a
global minimum at all or any minimum and
then we're just not going to get
convergence
and so that's kind of the knobs
returning here and so in classical
physics you know we have say a ball and
it goes and gets stuck in this local
minimum and there's been a ton of
intellectual resources and like Bob that
have gone into or how do you get into
the global minimum and we have some
techniques and strategies and they they
work more or less but they don't
guarantee a global minimum and if there
is a property that does guarantee about
global minimum it's usually very
expensive to compute the quantum
contrast is that we actually can have a
particle hop to the ground energy state
through a barrier so we actually will
see that it'll tunnel right through and
so this is this is quite an odd behavior
and this is actually a a basic idea
around the model of quantum computation
called adiabatic quantum computation
which is analogous to simulated
annealing and classical computation if
you're familiar with that I won't get
too much into this but this is another
you know property that you should be
aware of in thinking about this space so
what's the general quantum algorithmic
framework well as I see it and I can't
say it's completely comprehensive you
start by initializing qubits to
represent the problem specific
Hamiltonian and a Hamiltonian is
essentially describing the energy of a
system in this case and then you repeat
until the error is reduced to a defined
probability you apply an algorithm a
specified sequence of gates
simultaneously to the qubits and this is
the core of your computation this is
where you're basically taking that
Hamiltonian and manipulating it in a way
that you can start to surface up those
probability amplitudes that are
associated with the solution and at the
end you'll measure the resulting
properties and this will probably the
yield the solution so algorithms
actually called algorithms will
oftentimes have an Associated error
which is essentially saying that this
algorithm will get you the right answer
with this many iterations or this many
computations up to this small error term
and so what's an example of how this
looks well here we have Grover's
algorithm and this is an algorithm
for oftentimes it's discussed in the
terms of unstructured database search
and so what you have is two cubits right
here that are entangled and essentially
we're moving across time towards the
right and we start by applying what's
called a Hadamard gate and this is you
know this is the zero of zero this is
our guaranteed position right now we
know that the system is in a zero zero
state and this is our target right now
but we don't actually know that and so
we apply a Hadamard gate and that's puts
the bits into stuporous position so
they're entangled together and that
means they have equal probabilities
right now and then we apply a u gate and
what this does is it actually flips the
solution down right and this is this is
kind of interesting and you might think
like okay well we have a you have
something that you know different maybe
we can find a solution but this is you
know this could be a negative
probability amplitude and while the
other ones could be positive and so you
still have like a 25% chance of getting
the right answer so you don't actually
know that this is going to yield the
right answer
so the core of this algorithm is what's
called Grover's diffusion operator and
what it does is it uses that quantum
interference to amplify the probability
amplitudes of the solution while
reducing using destructive interference
the erroneous solutions and so you see
this growing that the probability and
then you can after Oh square root and
cycles you can actually come very close
to a guarantee of the right answer and
so what does that kind of translate to
in terms of computational complexity
well you know the classical search is
actually not that complex it's Oh N and
right and that's the blue line right
there but the quantum search is
surprisingly efficient you only have to
search the list Oh square root n times
using this this method to arrive at what
is most likely the right answer and so
you can imagine searching a list of a
hundred items and having to only look
ten times to get the solution which is
kind of defies common sense
so as mentioned we also have Shor's
algorithm and Grover's algorithm gives
you a pretty reasonable speed up but
it's not one that is you know it's not
earth-shattering maybe maybe interesting
but not earth-shattering in and Shor's
algorithm is actually an algorithm that
you know it has an exponential speed-up
so it essentially computes these prime
factorizations as I mentioned and it
exploits this hidden structure using a
period finding algorithm I won't get too
much into it but it then uses these
periods of the prime numbers to analyze
Fourier transforms to create a super
polynomial speed-up versus its class old
counterpart and so at this point you may
be like okay cool like how is this
relevant right and so I'll start by
talking a bit about you know Network
inference so there are actually a lot of
algorithms and quantum algorithms I've
been published around network network
inference so for graft reversals
shortest path or Larian tors
clique finding cycles finding collisions
measuring vertex sensualities and then
also connectivity through a directed
graph and assessing bipartite nests so
there's quite a few our rhythms and this
is not an exhaustive list and so to give
you a relevant example a protein
receptor with different amino acids can
maintain structural Simoneau the
similarities which can yield cross
reactivity with a ligand or a binding
partner and so we can actually use this
maximal clique finding algorithm to
explore these similarities in structure
using what's known as a protein contact
graph in a protein contact graph the
vertices are the amino acids and the
edges are the points of contact between
those amino acids if you think about the
outer topology of the protein if you
find a maximal clique that's a shared
topological structure between say two
proteins that they show you that clique
and it would be extra interesting if
that clique is in a protein domain
because then they potentially have some
cross reactivity
and so here's an example of clicks that
would be found in a graph these are
essentially to describe a clique it is a
maximally connected set of nodes with
edges between each of them and so
there's also a few algorithms have been
proposed for genetics and sequencing so
quite a few multiple sequence algorithms
some of the interesting ones include
Homburg who use Grover's algorithm or
describe the theoretical application
growth album for multiple sequence
alignment informant formulated that we
also have Michelle I have in vataj and
they described a quantum evolutionary
algorithm for doing multiple sequence
alignment and then we also have quantum
simulation of fragile thorough genetic
trees and this was proposed by illness
in Jarvis in 2011 and given the
structure of some of these problems and
also the fact that we can potentially
use a lot of machine learning algorithms
quantum machine learning algorithms
there are some other potential
applications such as de novo assembly
gene linkage analysis variant analysis
and sequence homology and so another as
I hinted the the other application that
I see is in machine learning and you
know for there were there are three
authors in 2009 who published an
algorithm harro Hasidim and lloyd and
the algorithm is for solving linear
equations and this was a very
motivational paper in this space and
preceding them and and and even since
then there's there's been a lot of
algorithms I've been proposed quantum
variants of well-known agronomic rhythms
we use in barn from attics and clinical
informatics all the time so quantum
SVM's by rug entrustment Oceanian lloyd
in 2013
quantum neural networks these were
proposed by LTS key in 2001 and recently
simulated in 2018 by Farhi and doctrine
and then there's others that have been
proposed such as quantum regression
decision trees hidden Markov models
k-means and camión
and then this is kind of you know I know
there's a lot of clinical
implementations and this is by no means
my real area of expertise at all but
there are potentially some areas where
they this could be relevant if you think
about quantum encryption that could be
relevant to EHRs particularly when we
think about you know when Shor's
algorithm was published people said oh
it's going to break encryption at some
point in the future and that that may
still be true and but there's quantum
algorithms for encrypting that may be
resistant to those attempts consuming
communication can also be essentially
reveal when a third party is actually
looking at a communication line so for
that reason it may have security
communication run on a network and then
also we can think about logistics so if
you think about say it say a team or
organization has a set of tasks they
need to accomplish and they have members
or groups within them that they need to
optimize resource distribution among
them potentially optimizing resource
distribution can be improved with such
algorithms so in exploring the space
I've kind of mentally been developing a
framework and this isn't the complete
thing but I think this kind of speaks to
a lot of the ideas which is essentially
that we have a problem say in this case
I picked a random one Network State
attainability
and this can be reduced to a boolean
satisfiability and we could call this a
search algorithm and the application
that had mine was a biological network
threat ability and I'm not really sure
this is really an interesting question
this was just an example and so the
question is given in an abnormal
signaling pathway is there a
perturbation that will alter it into the
normal state and so right now 2sat is an
np-hard problem and this is the
complexity for a class school computer
this is the complexity for a quantum
computer you see that the quantum
computer slightly improves upon that and
you see that with the exponent term that
basically halves it right there and so
is their application in quantum
application novel yeah probably because
I just kind of made it up but
but you know the the idea is that if we
were thinking about some more serious
problems we would actually assess you
know are these novel applications
you know why are they novel is it
because they could actually make
something more you know is it because
they have not been considered could they
actually not make something more
tractable or will they make something
more tractable and then so you know kind
of looking the present and count moving
towards the practical you know what are
some of the gaps that I see in kind of
thinking about this technology in the
space of biology and informatics well
there what are the relevant computations
in problems and computational problems
in biology medicine that content
algorithms may help address I think
that's one of the biggest questions they
you know if you have these algorithms
what are what can we use to use them for
and then what are the reductions in time
complexity that these algorithms may
provide in finding solutions to these
problems so do they actually even
improve over the classical algorithm you
know are we going to have someone like
Erin tang
actually develop a really clever
classical algorithm that shows no
improvement or kind of eclipses at the
quantum improvement rather and then
which improvements will actually
translate into a meaningful improvement
in our ability to understand research or
deliver care you know where can where
will an improvement actually makes sense
given the resources will probably have
to deploy to make it happen and then
what are the minimal examples of each
computational problem for which we can
develop proof of concept you know how
how can we illustrate binding with maybe
a very you know a small immuno or amino
acid sequence or some biological
molecule and will that be you know
interesting motivational and then can we
demonstrate a quantum advantage by
comparing efficiency of the quantum in
classical algorithms so this is you know
this is already something that's being
researched quite intensely this year
among other spaces and it would be
interesting to see whether
demonstrations in the biological space
would be useful for you know for
practical purposes in the future
and so where we are now where what in
what's called the noisy intermediate
scale quantum era and that was a coined
a term coined by John Prisco who's a
professor at Caltech and so we have
quantum computers and you can actually
publicly access them
for example iBM has a five and sixteen
qubit system that they product or
multiple systems that they've
productionize through an API and they
also have a 50 cubic prototype that's
not yet available but these are these
already have programmable API you know
Python you can actually you know make it
make a login you know work of the API
download it and run real computations on
a real pump and computer intel has a 49
qubit chip that they've discussed it's
as far as I know it's currently
undergoing testing in the Netherlands
and this this company qtek but there's
really a few details around that
Righetti computing is a startup that's
very well funded in this space they have
a 19 qubit API that's been productionize
dand they also have a 128 hybrid api
that they've been out for 2019 and that
was just last week so will be
interesting whether they have been that
milestone and Google has a 72 jiva chip
that they've claimed they're targeting
for this year but the year is quickly
coming to a close so it's gonna be
interesting to see whether they hit that
milestone they have no published error
rates but their goal is to essentially
go for the error rates they have on the
90 bit chip which were quite low and
then there's d-wave which is kind of an
interesting case it's a little different
from the others they have a 2,000 cubits
chip which sounds like a lot but they as
far as I know have no published error
rates and it's it does a very specific
model quantum computation analogous to
simulated annealing and it's a bit
controversial and it seems that the
architecture of the system is not quite
flexible enough to demonstrate quantum
speedups on a lot of problems that
people would be interested in so so they
do get speed ups on very specific
instances when it matches the
architecture really
but how meaningful that is is
questionable and so if we look ahead you
know we have these this this kind of
mark at forty nine cubits so around
forty nine fifty cubes this is where a
supercomputer in you know one of the
largest supercomputers in the world
would not be able to actually simulate
the system because there's a number of
exponential states and so this is kind
of a question this is the fuzzy area
boundary like where we start to see a
quantum advantage once we go past this
number of qubits and I think that's
really what you know Google and Righetti
are driving towards but the big question
is that can you do that while keeping
air rates down as you entangle more
qubits it gets quite difficult to keep
these error rates down because of this
property known as decoherence and you
know if we do get to that point
whatever the early applications we have
these you know potentially quite noisy
qubits are there algorithms that
actually are resilient to that noise and
i actually recently saw an example of an
algorithm that in fact is resilient at
noise for more modeling and molecular
hydrogen that was published in 2016 and
so noise might actually for certain
instances noise may not be a deal
breaker but clearly if we wants a scale
computation and really realize its full
potential we need to address the noise
issue and this will probably come in the
farther future in decades with fully
error corrected quantum computation and
so what are the challenges and unknowns
regarding this hardware well you know
can we scale scale a quantum computer to
the size required for modeling modeling
meaningful computational problems and I
think you know most people think that
that's probably going to be the case but
it hasn't been done yet and it's not
really
guaranteed can logical universality be
made to scale and so what this means is
that we have a set subset of quantum
gates that we can use to make a
universal quantum computer and those
gates and their configurations actually
be scaled correctly and then we have
quantum computation is it actually more
powerful than a classical computer
computational theorists actually don't
know this for sure like you know it's
it's it there's a lot of good
indications that it will be it's clearly
very different but does that actually
translate into a more powerful model
that's actually an open question and
then what will the pace of hardware
development be we've seen hardware
development progressed very rapidly for
silicon chips over the decades and to
some degree we have we have a you know
we have a track to follow we've already
done this with silicon can we do it with
a quantum system and so that's that's
kind of interesting maybe we have an
upper hand and you know or a little bit
of a lift in that regard but you know is
it gonna follow anything's now I guess
with Moore's law i I think that's that's
not particularly clear right now and so
to give some historical perspective you
know this here is actually a memory unit
from a univac one computer from 1951
from Reddington rands and you can see
it's visually actually quite similar in
structured so like a this 50 qubit
prototype in IBM and you know I think
the big I don't think is like these are
actually quite large systems and the
chip for the computer is actually here
in a refrigerated cooling unit and these
are essentially microwave coax cables
that control the qubits but you can see
the control control structures are quite
large can you reduce the Clinch control
structures you know what what's the
miniaturization look for these computers
is even relevant and most people think
that these computers are can be accessed
through cloud API so maybe that's not as
important but I think the the big idea
here is that you know in 1951 we didn't
really know the impact that digital
computers would have on the world and
well I don't think a quantum computer
will be quite the same I think in terms
of science science and research
endeavors these could actually be really
really valuable in the future and we
don't really know how valuable they may
be so with that you know I'm a little
bit optimistic as to what they what
applications they may find in the future
and so with that I'd like to acknowledge
my advisor Shanna McQueen
let me you know kind of pursue this bit
bit of a harebrained topic and and
gwandma true and Lisa Carson's for the
green to come here today and and kind of
helping me bounce some ideas off
regarding this topic and then Dianne
document well helping organize this and
then of course my photos and pears
demise OHSU and then the NIH NIH as per
supporting this research and there's a
training grant there great talk then so
from my very limited understanding a
quantum system is a probabilistic system
and it seems from your talk that by
getting humans to think
probabilistically which is really hard
to do we can solve problems that have
never been solved before do you think
training in so-called quantum thinking
could be more helpful decision-making in
healthcare well that's a great question
I am not so I'm not sure that
necessarily is true I think in terms of
developing algorithms it can be useful
because you're thinking about abstract
problems in a very similar way I think a
lot of the power of this quantum
thinking comes not just from the
probabilistic component which is you
know that's that's interesting and in
definite part of those systems but it's
not really you know it's not really the
what I would say really defines these as
a different multiple structure two
structures you can work with I think
this idea of more entanglement being
able to cause interferences and and this
idea of superposition and kind of you
suspended states in a hilbert space like
those are kind of ideas that you may be
able to work with to
kind of think about certain algorithms
and computational problems differently
I'm not sure I mean yeah that's a great
question I I can't bring you an exact
example of the top of my head and I'm
guessing you're referring to biological
problems so I think you know well the
one example I had with contact graph or
protein that may be one one way to kind
of explore this and that would be an act
like a clique finding and it
specifically maximal clique right is
what yeah
yeah that's true that's true yeah so I
I'm so I'm sorry good
yeah I mean that was a perfect aviv my
question is a little bit unclear to me
exactly what direction your your project
is going mm-hmm because you've given a
very good introduction as to how quantum
computing is working and maybe the et
the algorithms you're going to be
developing but it's not exactly clear to
me from your presentation what's the
application or what's what's the what
your project will be yeah and I think
you know to be completely clear
I haven't developed my proposal yet so I
can't say it's completed hashed out but
I do have kind of a tentative direction
that I'm looking for which is
essentially to explore the biological
movement space like what what biological
problems
are currently kind of hard to do or be
interesting to apply this these types of
algorithms to and then to kind of see
what the Delta is in terms of their
complexities and then from there the
rough divides minimal proof-of-concept
subproblems and try and understand you
know what is the smallest problem that
we can model that gets at this idea and
understand you know several of those and
then from there you know the hope is
that you know I can begin to start
actually you know developing those
proof-of-concept okay
sure I should have made that clearer
this isn't a proposal defense it's just
the symposium so he's just giving the
background around the area and the way
he's starting to think about it okay but
we don't require them
he will next term have to come up with a
proposal and then your question is dead
on if he gets the whole talking hasn't
answered that then but this but this is
that but this is the background just to
generate this kind of discussion and and
in fact the question that we just had
before around which problems and start
thinking about them that's what we
wanted people here to kind of think
about this about problems that currently
are seem intractable where there might
be something that he should be exploring
yeah and you did propose the show quite
a few of them and I thought there were
excellent problems for for for
investigation right yeah we run into
quite a few of those one of the things I
think I've talked to you about already
is thinking about how this might apply
to neuroimaging given that we're often
dealing with at this case right now
90,000 vertices in a given Network and
that's just for an individual subject
depending on how you want to model
things so one of the things I wanted to
ask about is you spots you talked a
little bit about graph theory metric
that graph theory algorithms for
operating on networks and one of the
concerns I have with a quantum computer
given the number of qubits how big of a
network can you really handle with
current algorithms so makes me wonder
like so so maybe the next challenge is
trying to figure out how to be able to
handle something like a 90,000 vertex
Network which we can do on a digital
computer pretty quickly and easily
well not quickly and easily we can we
can do it so just just a thought I think
that's absolutely right
you know I think part of that will be
sold by scalability but you know
potentially there are you know
opportunities to do some sort of
sampling approaches for the network but
that still doesn't solve a lot of the
issues that we come up with with the
classical computers so how do you go
about really yeah so for example you
could use a multi scale algorithm and
then develop multiple levels of the
network so you limit the amount of
vertices you're loading in yeah so like
well we're on the subject of networks
and this is more of a comment like being
in academia like you know everyone has
to bloviate but so I you know I think
there is so there are some really
interesting interesting problems like
you know I've been really thinking about
random walk based algorithms and I think
there is some sort of connection between
kind of the probabilistic nature of
quantum of basically random walks and
basically so I mean I you know I I'm
just kind of I'm trying to make the
connections right now I just don't know
exactly what what they are sure so
actually you know by some accounts of
random walk is considered by a palm to
computer primitive so it is actually a
process that you can
okay this is me okay that just really
made my head hurt
[Laughter]
Thanks I let the question in quantum
computers is yes concept like RAM so the
space you talk about the time complexity
but how people like really discussed
about is is space complexity like how
big is this case how big a network may
really be harder for quantum computing
these kind of yeah so there is a there's
something known as quantum I'm CUBAN and
that is an area that's you know been
discussed a lot and and one of the
interesting questions around it is that
you know because because you're
restoring these you know when you're
using R and you're storing data
structures in it and there's a there's a
right time in the real time and one of
the questions around these algorithms is
you may have a very efficient algorithm
but if it relies on the QM which only
has a certain which has a certain you
know complexity when it comes to writing
and reading memory does that actually
reduce the games you have so Ram is
definitely a concept and it actually it
does have a lot of implications another
related question Christians caching so
it is I believe it is probabilistic
computing so how can people actually a
deputy's kind of probabilistic a
computing into logical computing what
you should not be like in the current
classical computation really
deterministic yeah is there some kind of
three owners and occupied resources
yeah why don't you go ahead with your
okay yeah so I think so how can you
adapt you know a probabilistic system to
actually do some deterministic logical
permutations and I think that you know
when you when you do those measurements
that ends up you know being I mean is
probabilistic behind that you
essentially have this you know the
classical world is deterministic and I
mean I don't have a great answer for you
I think that I think that there are some
algorithms that are deterministic I
think maybe you can correct me but but
there's a lot of algorithms do adopt
this probabilistic framework and you you
don't have a guarantee but you have
something pretty close which is a very
high probability down to a very smaller
you know error term of getting the wrong
answer you know how you scale that
towards a more you know seemingly
determinist
a graphical model computing okay is this
so-called like a basic network okay
Polly we can talk about this Oh
so to answer your question to some
degree I have seen papers you know
my only contribution to this is maybe
think about Bayesian ISM and I think
there is probably some very strong
connections between kind of the Bayesian
way of probabilistic thinking and
quantum pop computation in fact there is
there's a Wikipedia page on it school I
actually haven't you know that's a
really great point I haven't really
explored that a whole lot but I mean it
makes sense any other questions comments
yeah
[Applause]